WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
START THIS A HEARING FOOD
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. WILL CALL THE MEETING
TO ORDER WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE FIRST.
AS WE GET OUR MEMBERS. COMING IN
WILL. CALL THE QUORUM THEN.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
FIRST CALL.
AB TWO TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX
LACKEY. SO REMEMBER LACKEY
COMES.
PUT IN PLACE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON ISSUE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
IT'S SUPER PROTECTION PROPOSAL
THAT WILL ENHANCE.
THE CAR PURCHASING EXPERIENCE.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE CHAIRMAN'S COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX WILL
REQUIRED USED CAR SALESPEOPLE.
THE COMPLETE THE SAME CONTINUING
EDUCATION COURSE THE DEALERS ARE
REQUIRED TO TAKE.
THERE'S NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION
ON FILE AND WITH ME TODAY.
ARE BILLION LARRY FROM THE
INDEPENDENT AUTOMOBILE.
DEALERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WHO
REPRESENT PLEASE.
LET'S CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BILL DOOR
IN LOBBYIST FOR THE.
INDEPENDENT OR DEALS
ASSOCIATION. WITH BEEN WORKING
ON THIS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS WE
PUT THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION
THAT FOR DEALERS.
AND DIEM THEY NOTICED A MARKED.
IMPROVEMENT OVER.
REDUCING OVER INVESTIGATION OF
CLAIMS. AND I HAVE WITH ME LARA
LOSS COUNSELOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ANYBODY HAS ANY
QUESTIONS.
WE LIKE TO PROCEED WITH THE SAME
ANSWER.
WE'RE JUST AS QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
HAVE A WILL TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
HE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
LIKED DESPITE OPPOSITION TO
SHARON OPINION ON THE AUTHORS.
SING ON ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
I HAVE A MOTION BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG MISTER
FUNG.
SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER MATHIS.
WHICH I CLOSE WAS LIKE.
I THANK YOU FOR ARE WORKING WITH
MY. OFFICE.
WITH WITH THIS.
.
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL MISTER CHAIR
WE. WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY HAVE A GROUP
TO DO THAT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL RE
INTRODUCE A MOTION. MISTER FUNG
WAS VERY ZEALOUS AND TRYING TO
GET YOU MOVING.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
AS WE AS WE GET A CALL WILL
TAKE ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO MUCH.
MISTER I DON'T.
TWENTY SEVEN TWELVE.
SEE WHEN YOU READY GOOD AFTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT TWO THOUSAND EIGHT PROP IT
ONE A A WAS PASSED BY THE VOTERS
THIS WAS JERRY BROWN'S HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
BUT WAS NEVER SOLD PROPERLY
CALIFORNIA VOTERS WE WAS
ORIGINALLY PITCHED THIS PROJECT
WAS GOING TO BE FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AND WOULD HAVE
BEEN A DIRECT ROUTE CONNECTING
THE MAJOR CITIES OF CALIFORNIA.
INSTEAD WHAT HAPPENED IS COSTS
HAVE SKYROCKETED IN THIS
BOONDOGGLE OF A PROJECT.
CURRENT ESTIMATES HOW THE COST
OVER SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. IN THESE US WAS ALWAYS
SEEM TO GO ONE DIRECTION WOULD
YOU BE REVISED UPWARD.
THIS BILL IS VERY SIMPLE.
IT WOULD IT REQUIRE THAT. ALL OF
THE EXISTING BONDS THAT HAVE
BEEN AUTHORIZED FOR ONE EIGHT
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
ARE IMMEDIATELY CANCELLED IN THE
PROCEEDS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
RAISED WILL BE DISTRIBUTED BACK
TO THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS IN
THE FORM OF REFUNDS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN JERRY
BROWN'S BULLET TRAIN YOU KNOW
WHERE SHOULD NEVER BE BUILT WE
SHOULD DEFINE IT WE SHOULD BE
FUNDED IMMEDIATELY BEFORE MORE
CALIFORNIA'S TAXPAYERS MONEY IS
WASTED. CALIFORNIA DOES NOT NEED
A HIGH SPEED RAIL CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS DO NOT WANT HIGH SPEED
RAIL THE TIME IS NOW LETS DE
FUND I SPEED RAIL LET'S RETURN
EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR. BACK WHERE
IT BELONGS THE POCKETS OF
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
MR ON.
GIVE ME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YEAH.
I AM MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
HE MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
VOICE AN OPINION OF THE AUTHORS.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE OFFICE.
BUT THE FIRST IN A SECOND.
CAN DO BECAUSE OF WE HAD SORT OF
A QUORUM.
SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS LEAVE THIS
OPEN UNTIL THE.
THAT WE RECEIVE A QUORUM WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE BY WITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
JERRY BROWN'S IDEA FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL WAS A BOON DOG FROM
THE BEGINNING CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
NEED THIS FOR THE SECOND WORST
ROADS A NATION THE WORST TRAFFIC
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY. WE
ACTUALLY NEED DO IS IMPROVE OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED
TO FIX OUR ROADS AND EXPAND OUR
FREEWAYS WE DON'T NEED A HIGH
SPEED RAIL THAT NO CALIFORNIA
WANTS ANY THAT FUNERAL EVEN
RIDE.
WE HAVE SOUTHWEST AIRLINES IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN FLY ANYWHERE
IN THE STATE YOU WANT TO FOR
FIFTY NINE DOLLARS EACH WAY WITH
A TWO WEEK ADVANCE PURCHASE. YOU
CAN DRIVE OUR ROADS WHICH NEED
TO BE FIXED THIS IS OUR PRIORITY
DO NOT THIS HIGH SPEED RAIL.
BOONDOGGLES OF JERRY BROWN I
WOULD IN CLOSING UP PROPOSAL
ACTUALLY KEEP THE EXISTING
SECTION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL. IN
PLACE ON THE MIDDLE OF CENTRAL
VALLEY IT EASY A MONUMENT AND A
REMINDER TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE CAN HANG A SIGN ON IT
THE SIGN TO BE SIMPLE.
YOU CAN HAVE THREE WORDS GONNA
READ JERRY BROWN'S LEGACY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S DEFINE AT
HIGH SPEED RAIL MEANT SECRETARY
WEEKLY PLEASE CALL ROLE FOR A
QUORUM.
FRAZIER HERE
PHONE.
AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
MATHIS.
MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
REQUIREMENTS ARE GONNA CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE ON VOTE.
WOMEN IS GO BACK TO THE MOTION.
THEM MOST BY MISTER HARPER
WITHIN THEM A SECOND AYE MR FUNG
EXECUTIVE PLEASE SCHOOL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER NO FRAZIER NO
FONG. FONG AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
AND WE ARE CURRY NO BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY NO DALY NO FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT VOTING THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL NO.
FRIEDMAN NO.
SO HAS THREE AFFIRMATIVE VOTES
WILL LEAVE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE LOOKING FOR AN
AUTHOR SO IF WE DON'T MR MATHIS
WOULD YOU PLEASE.
WE DID.
WHAT IS THE ROLE ON MISTER LIKE
YOU OVER? WE'VE MISSED MATHIS
PLEASE OPEN RULING MR. LACKEY
PLEASE AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
THE MOTION YOU SKIP BACK IN
SYNC.
FIRST BY OF LONG SECOND BY
HARPER.
PLEASE CALL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR
CURRY. AND WE ARE CURRY AYE
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY BY DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER I AM MATHIS.
I MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THERE IS STILL WE'VE RULED BEEN.
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MR MATHIS AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A. B..
EIGHTEEN NINETY EIGHT A BILL
WHICH SEEKS TO ADDRESS OUR
SERIOUS AND GROWING PROBLEM. OF
WIDESPREAD HOMELESSNESS.
THIS MEASURE SEEKS TO EXPAND
UPON EXISTING LAW.
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN.
WHICH STATES THAT CALTRANS SHALL
OFFER ONLY THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO THE ABILITY TO
LEASE PROPERTY FOR EMERGENCY.
SHELTERS AND FEEDING PROGRAMS
FOR ONE DOLLAR A MONTH.
I OPPOSE THIS MEASURE LAST YEAR.
BECAUSE THAT CHOSE TO IGNORE THE
SERIOUSNESS OF HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE
STATE.
HOMELESSNESS IS NOT LIMITED TO
SAN FRANCISCO.
YET WE OFFER THIS LOW COST
OPPORTUNITY.
TO THE MOST AFFLUENT URBAN AREA
IN THE COUNTRY.
IF IT WAS GOOD ENOUGH FOR SAN
FRANCISCO.
IT OUGHT TO BE GOOD ENOUGH
FOR THE REST OF THE STATE.
WE CANNOT STAND BY WHITE PEOPLE
STRUGGLE TO FIND HOUSING OPTIONS
AND HOT MILFS.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF UN SHELTERED
HOMELESS.
OF ANY STATE IN THE NATION AT
SIXTY SIX
PERCENT.
CALIFORNIA ALSO RANKS AS THE
SECOND HIGHEST.
FOR CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
POPULATIONS.
WELL THERE HAS BEEN SOME
HEADWAY.
WITH REGARD TO EFFORTS TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
MANY WHO ARE CURRENTLY HOMELESS
HAVE SLIPPED THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WITHOUT PROACTIVE EFFORTS THESE
NUMBERS WILL CONTINUE TO GROW.
ONE SUCH OPTION IS TO EXPAND ON
LAST YEAR'S EFFORTS.
CALTRANS OWNS NUMEROUS. ON USE
PARCELS OF LAND MANY OF WHICH
ARE LOCATED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THIS AMENITIES OFTEN LACK THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
HOMELESS SERVICES
FOOD ASSISTANCE.
AND COMMUNITY PARKS FOR THEIR
RESIDENTS.
IN FACT.
OF THE EXISTING CONTINUE ARMS OF
CARE ORGANIZATIONS CURRENTLY
SERVING HOMELESS POPULATIONS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND LOS
ANGELES HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF HOMELESS WITHOUT ADEQUATE
ACCESS.
TWO FORMS OF SHELTER.
ONE SUCH SOLUTION TO THESE REESE
REOCCURRING CHALLENGES.
CAN BE FOUND.
WITHIN THE ACTIVE USE.
OF PRESENTLY UNUSED PARCELS OF
LAND.
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY A. WOULD
REQUIRE CALTRANS TO LEASE ON
YEARS PARCELS OF LAND APPLE LOW
MARKET RATES.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF CONSTRUCTING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND FOOD
PANTRY LOCATIONS.
IT IS THROUGH THIS PARTNERSHIP.
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CAN PROVIDE REAL SOLUTIONS.
TO ITS HOMELESS AND AT RISK
RESIDENTS.
FURTHERMORE.
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY EIGHT ALLOWS
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF OPEN AIR
SPACES
AND RECREATIONAL PARKS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ULTIMATELY THIS BILL AIMS TO
EASE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR RESIDENTS
AND PUT VACANT LAND.
GOOD USE
AT A NOMINAL*.
I ASKED YOU AFFIRM YOUR
COMMITMENT TO ASSIST OUR
HOMELESSNESS.
AND AT RISK POPULATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE.
MISTER MATHIS HAVE YOU.
ENTERTAINED THE FACT OF THE.
EXCEPTING THE COMMITTEES OF
AMENDMENTS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS
DO NOT OFFER THE SHALL THEY
MAKES IT OPTIONAL TO CALTRANS
AND AGAIN IF THIS IS GOOD ENOUGH
FOR. SAN FRANCISCO IT OUGHT TO
BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR THE REST OF
THE STATE ALSO BELIEVE THERE'S A
SIMILAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
EXTENDING THIS. ONLY TO THE CITY
OF OAKLAND.
THAT IS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
I ENCOURAGE.
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
OPEN THIS UP TO THE ENTIRE
STATE.
SO THAT WHO I'LL TAKE IS A NO I
WILL NOT BE TAKING THE WHO CAN
FISCAL LAST COMMITMENTS TO YOU
HAVING WITNESSES FOR MR MATHIS.
SEEING NONE ANYWHERE MET MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF WAS AN OPINION OF
YOU. THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
THEY THE FIRST BY MISTER HARPER
SECOND BY MISTER PHONE.
HOW MR MATHIS WHICH LIKE CLOSE?
S. AGAIN MEMBERS.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED.
EXACT SAME LEGISLATION.
TO USE THESE PARCELS THAT ARE
NOT BEING USED BY CALTRANS.
SO THAT WE ARE CITIES.
OR DISADVANTAGED AREAS.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEM FOR OUR
HOMES.
NOW WHY IS IT.
THE.
STRONGEST MOST VIBRANT STATE.
WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD.
WE'RE NOT GONNA OPEN THIS
PROGRAM UP FOR THE REST OF THE
STATE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO SO.
SAN FRANCISCO CAN DO IT IF WE
HAVE.
MEASURES OUT THERE TO OPEN ITS
OAKLAND WE DON'T EVEN NEED TO
OPEN ITS OAKLAND IF WE PASS THIS
WE CAN OPEN IT TO THE ENTIRE
STATE. TO LA TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHERE IT'S TRULY NEEDED I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS HOW.
WELL I SUPPORT THEME OF YOUR
BILL. TODAY I REQUEST REQUIRING
CALTRANS WHO DO THIS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE LEADS TO WASTE.
AND ONE ACCOMPLISH WHAT YOU
THINK IT WILL.
I CANNOT SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO AMEND THE SHALL TO
MAY FINISH I COULD SUPPORT.
A META SECTOR WHICH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER FRAZIER NO
FONG. FONG AYE AND WE ARE CURRY
NO AND WE ARE CURRY NO BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY NO DALY NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA MELENDEZ AREA.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL NINE.
IT'S THREE SIX WE'VE WILL RULE
OPEN FOR UP TO MEMBERS THEY
SERGEANTS TRICK FIND US SOME
AUTHORS PLEASE.
WE'RE GOOD.
WITH THE ANNOUNCEMENT SOME
MEASURES ON CONSENT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY
THREE OH SEVEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY SEVEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
THIRTY
SEVENTY SEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN AB THIRTY TO FORTY SIX.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ACR ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT THOSE ARE THE
MEASURES ON CONSENT.
BILL A FILE IS NUMBER THREE.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
MULLIN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
SO WE HAVE ALSO I'D ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK MEDICINE OF FIRST PLACE
SOME REMEMBER FONG SAID SEGWAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER. BEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CAN CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR
CURRY. AND WE ARE CURRY AYE
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHAU.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
INDIANA INEZ ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
MISTER CHAIR I'M A YES I'M SORRY
I MISSED THE COLUMN A YES ON THE
CONSENT.
GREENLEE I THANK YOU.
LETTERS NINE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO WE'LL MOVE FORWARD WITH THE.
AT THE END OF THE HEARING
PLEASE.
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND.
.
HAVE.
MISTER CELLS COME FORWARD
PLEASE YOU HAVE TO BILLS.
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND.
GO THROUGH AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS A PRESENT FOR
YOU SIMPLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE THE AIR
BE TO PRIORITIZE. THE RETROFIT A
REPLACEMENT OF THE MOST
POLLUTING SCHOOL BUSES THAT
OPERATE IN AIR DISTRICTS
DESIGNATED. BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS EXTREME NON
ATTAINMENT FOR OZONE POLLUTION.
FOLLOWED BY OUR DISTRICTS AND
THEN I HAVE MEDIUM THEIR
DISTRICTS
NO MORE THAN NINETY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVING COUNTIES
WITH UNHEALTHY AIR. I'VE MEMBERS
IS JUST A SIMPLE MEASURE THAT
SAYS WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE
REPLACING OLD SCHOOL BUSES FOR
SCHOOL CHILDREN THAT ARE
BREATHING OLD.
THOSE EMISSIONS FROM THOSE OLD
BUSES AND WE SHOULD DO THAT UP
AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE. I
HAVE I THINK WE SHOULD AS A
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE.
.
MAKING SURE KIDS ARE HEALTHY
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE IN
SCHOOL BUSES THAT HAVE EITHER
BEEN RETROFITTED ARE WITH THE
CLEANEST AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE TO THEM. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT.
MISTER SAUCIER BE WITNESSES
SUPPORT I DON'T THINK THEY MADE
IT OUT.
SO WHAT THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY.
I AM.
CRISTINA YOU ABSENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SYLVIA SOLELY SHOP
BEHALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
UNIFIED AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THE SCHOOL BUSES FLEETS IN
OUR DISTRICT ARE AMONG SOME OF
THE OLDEST IN THE STATES SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THINKING.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE HE MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR VOICE AN OPINION
OF THE AUTHORS.
SEEN ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHORED MR
MATHIS.
MR SALSA AND LOVE THE DIRECTION
YOU'RE TAKING ON THIS MY MY
CONCERN IS I ALSO COVER A VERY.
RURAL AREA WITH INYO COUNTY
WHICH IS ALSO KNOWN FOR HAVING
HORRIBLE AIR QUALITY IN YOUR
BILL DOES NOT COVER THEM. AND
YOU WILL WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
TAKE AN AMENDMENT TO TO ENSURE
THAT PRESENT A LANGUAGE I HAVE
BEEN IN THE BRIEFING I GOT IT
WAS NOT THERE. CORRECT MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU THROUGH
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THE LANGUAGE
AS ADDRESSED IN THE BILL NOW
ACTUALLY GOES ADDRESSES. AREAS
AS WELL SO WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT
THE MOST POLLUTED AREAS WE WANT
THAT PRIORITIZATION FOR THOSE
KIDS ARE BREATHING THOSE. BAD
AIR EMISSIONS SO THAT THEY DON'T
BUT.
AND IT LEGISLATION THE WAY IT'S
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO SPELL IT OUT FOR
YOU. IN THE BILL WILL ADDRESS
PLACES LIKE IT.
PARAMOUNT ALL LAYOFF TODAY MORE
WORK ON.
WELL IT'S IN THERE. APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MISTER CELLS WHICH
ARE CLOSE I JUST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS I JUST THINK THIS IS A
GOOD PROGRAM FOR KIDS UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE. IT'S A
GOOD PROGRAM TO.
PRIORITIZE THOSE OLD SCHOOL
BUSES SO YOU CAN GET THEM OFF
THE.
HE WAS FOR CELLS THANK YOU.
SO MR SELSUN CLEAR WHAT THE
INTENT OF YOUR BILL IS. PROP ONE
BE APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
HELPING REMOVE OLD AND TOXIC
FROM THE ROAD.
PROP ONE BE MONEY ALLOCATE THIS
HAS SERVED ITS PURPOSE AND NOW
ALL THE MONEY'S GONE.
I CANNOT SUPPORT A BILL IS PRIOR
THAT PRIORITIZES FUNDING WITHOUT
FIRST GOING WITH FUNDING IS.
FOR THAT REASON ALL THE
ABSTAINING FROM YOUR BILL TODAY.
LAND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MISTER CAREFULLY NOTICES
MY CAN HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
ADDRESS THAT POINT.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ON THE
ISSUE OF PROPOSITION ONE BE A NO
THOSE FUNDS ARE GONNA LOOK AT
BEING EXPANDED BY THE END OF
THIS.
THIS YEAR I KNOW SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS ARE PROGRAMMED OUT THAT
WHAT WE'RE HOPING TO DO ON
POLICY OF THIS BILL. AND.
IN THE POLICY COMMITTEE IS
PRIORITIZE.
OLD SCHOOL BUSES GETTING OFF THE
ROAD.
WELL WE'RE LOOKING TO DO AS WE
MOVE INTO THE FISCAL COMMITTEE
INTO APPROPRIATIONS IS LOOK FOR
ANOTHER FUNDING SOURCE IN THAT
FUNDING SOURCE WERE OPEN.
SOMETHING CAN BE DONE UNDER CAP
AND TRADE SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED.
PREVIOUS.
SO WITH THAT I'D HOPE MEMBERS
WILL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION OF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
RECUSAL SHOULD FIVE MONTHS TO
GET THERE.
.
I'M ENTERTAINING MOTION.
THANK YOU.
I WON MOTION BY MISTER MEDINA
SECOND BY MISTER GIPSON.
MAD SECRETARY CALLED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER NOT
VOTING FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY NOT VOTING BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT IS SIX FOODS WILL LEAVE YOU
RULE PERHAPS MEMBERS MICHELLE'S
WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED WITH.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR NINETY
TWO.
WOULD REQUIRE THERE BE TO
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
FROM MEDIUM DUTY TRUCKS THERE
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE POUNDS. GROSS
VEHICLE WEIGHT RATING WELL THE
EXISTING RETIREMENT PROGRAM
REPLACEMENTS HELP REPAIR REPLACE
LIGHT DUTY TRUCKS A PASSENGER
VEHICLES. THESE PROGRAMS ARE
LIMITED TO VEHICLES WEIGHING
LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND.
AT POUNDS OF WHICH FILLS CAPTURE
A NUMBER OF MEDIUM DUTY TRUCKS
INCLUDING FLAT FLATBED TRUCKS
BLOCK STRUCK SUCH AS TWO TRUCKS.
CEMENT TRUCKS BOX VANS DUMP
TRUCKS DELIVERY TRUCKS.
AND SO FORTH AND THESE ARE THE
TRUCKS THAT HAVE LOWER VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED LOWER AVERAGE
SPEED BUT HAVE A LOT OF STOPS
AND STARTS LOTS OF IDLE TIME
THAT'S INCREASED EMISSIONS.
MR CHAIRMAN WERE JUST TRYING TO
DO IS TRY TO CAPTURE SOME OF
THESE THINGS THAT WE SEE ON OUR
ROADS. DAY IN DAY OUT THINGS
LIKE DELIVERY TRUCKS WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO THESE
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW FOR
RETROFITS OR.
HOPEFULLY EVENTUALLY
REPLACEMENT AS WELL FEARFUL
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS JUST
TRYING TO IMPROVE THE NATION'S
UP AND DOWN THE STATE THANK YOU.
SO FIRST AND SECOND ONE BY.
I'M HERE CURRY IN THE MISTER
MATHIS.
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES AND SORT
MISTER CELIS.
MAKE IT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE LIKES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY
SHALL WE HAVE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. AND.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT VALLEY FACES
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES MUST AND WHILE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE WE STILL
NEEDS. SIGNIFICANT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS TO MEET FEDERAL
HEALTH BASED AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS FOR PARTICULATE AND
OZONE.
AND MOBILE SOURCES ARE THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF THE MISSION
AND AND THEY'RE CURRENTLY
PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO ADDRESS
LIGHT DUTY AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES BUT NO PROGRAM EXIST
THAT WOULD CAPTURE THESE MEDIUM
DUTY VEHICLES. FOR THIS REASON
WE SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THINGS
YOU THINK YOU THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE LIKE TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE WE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR VOICE OUR OPINION
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NOT ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MISTER CELLS WHICH
LIKE CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RESEARCH ALSO SURE WE CAN RETIRE
REPLACE HIGH POLLUTING HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
BUT ALL THE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR CURRY. AND
WE ARE CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER
AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
ASSYRIAN.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT HAS ELEVEN WILL KEEP THE
ROLE BEEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS CAN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO. SEE THE
MISTER MOANS IN THE HOUSE.
MR MON.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR.
WELL IT WAS FULL THAT'S RIGHT.
THE MARK THAT.
SO MR MON AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN.
THAT'S THE ONE MISTER CHAIR.
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN.
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA SMART
CITY CHALLENGE GRANT PROGRAM.
TO ENABLE MUNICIPALITIES
TO COMPETE FOR GRANT FUNDING FOR
A MERGING TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGIES TO SERVE THEIR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM NEEDS.
THIS UP PROPOSAL BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IS MODELED AFTER
SUCCESSFUL FEDERAL GRANT PROGRAM
AND WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION THE CDC AND IT'S. A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ANNUAL REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE. TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN TASKS THE CTC WITH
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES AND
SELECTION CRITERIA FOR THE GRANT
PROGRAM IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
WORK GROUP. THAT WOULD INCLUDE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION ORGANIZATIONS
AND UC'S INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AMONG
OTHERS THIS BILL DOES NOT
PREDETERMINE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WILL BE AWARDED IN THE
GRANT.
WE WILL DETERMINE THAT THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS IN A FUTURE
YEAR ONCE THE CTC ESTABLISHES
THE GUIDELINES AND SELECTION
CRITERIA.
HAS HE ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT ONE
OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR FEDERAL
GRANT PROGRAM WAS SET THE
SEVENTY EIGHT PARTICIPATING
CITIES. THAT DEVELOPED SMART
CITY PLANS WERE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
POP AND PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT THEIR
RESPECTIVE VISIONS.
THAT NUMBER INCLUDED
TWELVE BUT PERMEATE PARDON ME.
ELEVEN CALIFORNIA CITIES
INCLUDING LONG BEACH.
RIVERSIDE AND MORENO VALLEY.
SAN JOSE SACRAMENTO OAKLAND IN
FRESNO SAN FRANCISCO WAS ONE OF
THE SEVEN NATIONAL FINALIST AND
RECEIVED ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC OUTREACH AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO FURTHER
DEVELOP ITS PLAN. I THINK THAT
WE CAN BUILD OFF OF THAT SUCCESS
AND SEND MORE CALIFORNIA CITIES
TO USE ADVANCED DATA AND
INTELLIGENT TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM TECHNOLOGIES AND
APPLICATIONS. THIS WILL HELP
ACHIEVE THE SIGNIFICANT GOALS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE OVERSEES
REDUCING CONGESTION ENHANCING
MOBILITY INSURING TRAVELER
SAFETY. ADDRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL
AND CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS.
SPURRING INNOVATION AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MR ALWAN REMEMBERS THE
PUBLIC BY TESTIFYING SCORE THE
BILL PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
WHO YOU REPRESENT PLEASE.
I AM MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF
OF QUALCOMM O'CLOCK COMES A
SENIOR BASED TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES REALLY THE LEADER IN
WIRELESS TECHNOLOGY IN. ANNA AND
A MAJOR PLAYER IN THE SAY IN THE
SMART CITY SPACE AND TIME TOLD
YOU TRANSPORTATION SPACE IN
WORKING WITH THE.
DOZENS OF OTHER COMPANIES AYE
NATIONWIDE ON.
ON SMART CITIES
GRANT CHALLENGES AND IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AND AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND.
ETCHED DEL AUTHOR CORRECTLY
STATED ALL THE REASONS FOR THIS
BILL AND WE SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THIS TAKEN ME REPRESENT PLEASE.
ANY MCPHERSON WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLINS LEADERSHIP AND
SPEARHEADING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
ALONG WITH THE PILOT PROGRAM TO
ENCOURAGE COMMUNITIES TO
CONSIDER THE INCOMING
TRANSPORTATION CHANGES BROUGHT
BY ADVANCING TECHNOLOGIES. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OR VOICE OUR
OPINION OF THE AUTHORS.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SUMMER THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EYE MONITORING FOR.
BUT THE QUESTION I HAVE THEY
JUST DON'T WANT TO BE FORGOTTEN.
IT GOES BACK TO.
I'M UNCLEAR HOW THIS BILL WILL
IS IN.
INTENDED TO SUPPORT RURAL
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AS WELL.
AND SOMETIMES WHEN WE START
TALKING ABOUT INCENTIVES AND
TECHNOLOGIES OF THOSE OF US IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND MAY NOT BE AT THE TABLE AND
SO I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT OVER.
AND I HOWEVER I WILL SUPPORT A
BILL TODAY IN HOPES THAT YOU
WILL MAKE SURE THAT I'M RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING ARE
INCLUDED.
CLOSER TO KEEP THAT MY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY ONE.
THE BILL OF THE A MOTION BY
MISTER GOETZ AND SECOND BY SOME
MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR SINGER.
MR LOW WAGE LIKE CLOTHES
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I DON'T
THINK YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU MISTER MOMENT.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING YOUR
BILL TODAY I LIKE THIS CONCEPT
HOPE THAT A PROGRAM LIKE THIS
CAN ENCOURAGE OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
TO CONSIDER HOW CHANGING
TECHNOLOGIES CAN ADDRESS SOME OF
OUR CHALLENGES AND WITH THAT
I'LL SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FUNG I AND WE
ARE CURRY. AND WE ARE CURRY AYE
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT IS TO KEEP THE RULE THROUGH
PERHAPS A MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER BOTH.
I WAS FIRST.
MISS MELINDA'S.
DON'T FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY AT ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROBLEMS FACING LOW INCOME
FAMILIES TODAY. IS THE ABILITY
TO GET THEIR CHILDREN TO AND
FROM SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
GRADE SCHOOL STUDENTS MISS
EIGHTEEN DAYS MORE SCHOOL ON
AVERAGE.
IN OVER THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
MISTER THIRTY SIX DAYS OR MORE
WHICH IS TWENTY PERCENT OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR.
OVER SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE CHRONICALLY
ABSENT OR LOW INCOME THIS IS
BECAUSE ONLY ONE IN EVERY TENTH
GRADE SCHOOL STUDENTS CAN AFFORD
RIDING THE BUS ON A WEEKLY
BASIS.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE
RECEIVED LITTLE TO KNOW FUNDING
TO PURCHASE SCHOOL BUSES BUT
THIS IS NOT BECAUSE THE STATE
DOES NOT HAVE THE MONEY. THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED TO ALLOW
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BE SPENT
ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
INSTEAD.
THE FUNDING LEFT FROM THE
EXISTING BOND FUND ALONE WOULD
ENSURE THAT EVERY CHILD CAN RIDE
THE BUS TO SCHOOL OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. WITH SEVENTY PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIANS SAYING THEY
WOULD LIKE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
FIFTY TWO PERCENT SAYING IT
SHOULD BE STOPPED OUT RIGHT. THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO BRING THIS
ISSUE BACK TO THE VOTERS
TAXPAYERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DECIDE WHETHER TO CONTINUE BY ME
FUNDING THIS TRAIN OR WHETHER
THEY WOULD LIKE TO INVEST IN OUR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY WELL UPON
A VOTER APPROVAL REALLOCATE THE
REMAINING BOND FUNDING FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SCHOOL BUS PROGRAM. THIS
LEGISLATION WILL ALLOW ALL
STUDENTS DESPITE A FAMILIES
INCOME TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO QUALITY EDUCATION BY REMOVING
BARRIERS TO ACCESS.
NO CHILD SHOT TO FALL BEHIND
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE UNABLE TO
GET TO SCHOOL HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS DAVID WALL FROM THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
PLEASE PROCEED SIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY.
MEMBERS WITH EACH PASSING DAY
IT'S CARD THAT THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECT IS SIMPLY NOT
VIABLE. THE RECENT DROP BUSINESS
PLAN SHOWS JUST HOW UNREALISTIC
THE PRODUCT OF THE PROJECT IS
BECOMING.
IT CONTINUES TO BANK ON ONGOING
FEDERAL FUNDING EVEN THOUGH IT'S
BEEN EIGHT YEARS SINCE THE ONLY
THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. INFUSION CAME AND NO
MONEY NO MORE MONEY APPEARS TO
BE FORTHCOMING. THERE'S BEEN
ZERO PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN THE
TRAIN NOR WILL THERE BE BECAUSE
THE STATE CANNOT OFFER MINIMUM
REVENUE GUARANTEES TO INVESTORS
WITHOUT VIOLATING THE PROVISION
IN MAYBE THIRTY THIRTY FOR. THE
GENERAL FUND SPENDING CAN BE
USED TO PROMOTE ONGOING
SUBSIDIES.
THE ONLY FUNDING REALLY KEEPING
THIS TRAIN OF PO A FLOWED AT
THIS PRESENT MOMENT CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS.
AND MEANWHILE MEMBERS THE COST
OF THE TREND CONTINUES TO CLIMB
THE FIRST SEGMENT IS NOW TWO AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS OVER
BUDGET AND CLIMBING. AND THE
OVERALL COST OF THE TRAIN IN THE
BUSINESS PLAN IS JUMPED FROM
SIXTY FOUR TO SEVENTY SEVEN
BILLION AND COULD GO AS HIGH AS
NINETY EIGHT BILLION.
MEMBERS I LOVE.
THE QUESTION MISTER FONG ASKED
LAST WEEK OF THE LA NOW IN THE
BUDGET FINANCE HEARING AND THE
ANSWER GIVEN WAS THAT THE TRAIN
IS SHORT BY FIFTY SIX TO SEVENTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHERE THE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO COME FROM.
THE BUSINESS PLAN DID PROVIDE A
PARTIAL ANSWER THE PLAN THAT WAS
RELEASED LAST MONTH AND THAT WAS
WE SHOULD EXTEND CAP AND TRADE
FROM TWENTY THIRTY TO TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY.
MEMBERS THAT SEEMS POLITICALLY
DICEY ESPECIALLY WHEN HIGH SPEED
RAIL IS NOT A GUARANTEE
ELIMINATOR OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
AND MEMBERS WHAT REALLY TALKING
ABOUT HERE WITH THIS PLAN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A BLENDED RAIL
PLAN THAT NO LONGER REPRESENTS A
TRADITIONAL HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM WHICH IS WHY LONGTIME
HIGH SPEED RAIL SUPPORTER.
CRETIN COPPICE PULL THIS SUPPORT
FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
AND.
.
AND THE LIST OF PROBLEMS EVEN
CONTINUES I MEAN AGAIN RIGHT
NOW.
THIS TRAIN WAS NEVER
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT A TRAIN THAT GOES FROM SAN
JOSE TO WASCO.
IT TERMINATES IN WASCO.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO BE
POLITICALLY VIABLE AND THE LIST
OF PROBLEMS EVEN CONTINUES GOING
ON FROM THERE? NO TRAIN IN THE
WORLD CAN CONSISTENTLY ACHIEVE
THE STATUTORY REQUIRED TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILES AN
HOUR.
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES WHICH IS WHAT WAS
REQUIRED IN AB THIRTY THIRTY
FOUR THERE'S THREE PLACES NOW ON
THE PROPOSED ROUTE WITH THE
TRAIN OFF THE THROTTLE BACK TO
HALF SPEED.
SO INSTEAD OF TAKING TWO HOURS
AND FORTY MINUTES TO GET FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES IT
COULD TAKE AS LONG AS FOUR
HOURS.
MEANWHILE MEMBERS THERE'S THIS
LITTLE THING CALLED SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE MORE
ATTRACTIVE TO BUSINESS
TRAVELERS.
HIGH SPEED RAIL SUPPORTERS CAN
FIGURE OUT WHAT DIRECTION TO
BILL THEN THEY'RE REALIZING THE
GOING OVER THE TEHACHAPI
MOUNTAIN RANGES ESSENTIALLY
IMPOSSIBLE. AND THEY DON'T HAVE
A PLAN B. TO GET THE TRAIN IN
THE LOS ANGELES AS MISS
MELINDA'S MENTIONED IT IS TIME
TO DO WHAT A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS DESIRE INPUT HIGH
SPEED RAIL BACK ON THE BALLOT.
FOR VOTERS TO CONSIDER ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
HIS MIND IS YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO LIKE
TO TESTIFY.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TEST MY
SUPPORTERS SO.
OFFERS BILL.
SEEN DONE ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
ELECT TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF
THE AUTHORS.
DECISION IN EUROPE SOMETHING
MISTER CHAIRMAN KEEPS DOWN ON
BEHALF ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED TRAINS. ALWAYS FIND
IT INTERESTING TO HEAR MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER WOLF EXPAND
UPON HIS KNOWLEDGE OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL AYE AYE HAVING TO LISTEN TO
THE EXPERTS TO LAST WEEK PRESENT
YOU WITH A BUSINESS PLAN TALKING
ABOUT.
EXCESS THAT THEY ARE LOOKING
TOWARDS WITH THE NEW LEADERSHIP
AT HIGH SPEED RAIL AMONG A
COMMENT BRIEFLY ABOUT THE NOTION
OF AIRPLANES WE NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT HERE IN CALIFORNIA OUR
AIRSPACE MUCH LIKE OUR HIGHWAYS
IS VERY CROWDED. THE NOTION THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE INCREASED
AIRLINE TRAFFIC HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IS SIMPLY NOT THE
TRUTH WE HAVE MILITARY BASES WHO
HAVE DEDICATED THEIR SPACE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WHICH
RESTRICT OUR ABILITY EXPAND
THOSE.
IN STATE AIRLINE MILES.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US WANT TO
SEE THE IMPACT THOSE BASES THAT
ARE HUGE ECONOMIC ENGINES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. ALSO LIKE
TO SAY THE LEADERSHIP HIGH SPEED
RAIL WHO MANY OF YOU HEARD DO A
PRESENTATION ON NEW BUSINESS
PLAN HAVE A DIRECTION AND THE
PLAN AND THE ABILITY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE VOTERS.
I WOULD ALSO REMIND YOU THAT
WE'VE HAD A VOTE ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL THE VOTERS A FIRM THAT THEY
WANT TO SEE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THEY HAVE HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY.
PRESENTED TO THEM THEY
RESPONDED AND THE NEW LEADERSHIP
AT THE AUTHORITY IS MOVING
FORWARD AND IS GOING TO MEET THE
NEED. THAT HAS NOT ONLY BEEN
DEMANDED BY THE VOTERS BUT ALSO
IS GOING TO HELP US WITH OUR
POLICY REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU
HEAR HAVE SET WITH REGARDS TO
REDUCING OUR CLIMATE IMPACT.
SO.
WITH RESPECT OUT ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
I THINK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OR
MAKE A COMMENT THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE AT ANY.
BUT ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LIKE TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS MISS
HARPER.
JUST AS I THINK I KIND OF A
NOTED IN REGARDS TO THE LAST.
THE LAST COMMENT.
JUST AS A ROUND TRANSPORTATION
WILL BE INVOLVING OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL DECADES AIR
TRANSPORTATION WILL B. INVOLVING
OVER THE. NEXT FEW DECADES WE
HAVE LOTS OF A.
I AIR BASES THAT HAVE BEEN
CONVERTED TO COMMERCIAL USE.
WHICH I PROBABLY WILL HAVE A
LOT OF.
UTILIZATION IN THE FUTURE AYE
AS AIRCRAFT EVOLVE OVER TIME.
MS BAKER.
THANK YOU I END THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS BILL
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE DID LISTEN
VERY CAREFULLY TO THE TESTIMONY
LAST WEEK.
IT WHICH OR THE PEER REVIEW
AUTHORITY MENTIONED THAT IT IS
THERE'S NO WAY THIS IS GOING TO
GO TWO HOURS AND FORTY MINUTES.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE POINTS
THAT IS A LITTLE BIT
DISHEARTENING AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
WE DO AS YOU'RE DOING TO SAY
TAKE A STEP BACK AND LOOK AT
WHAT MIGHT BE A BETTER
INVESTMENT OF THESE DOLLARS AND
THERE'S LOTS OF LEGISLATION TO
DO THAT BUT I'M APPRECIATIVE AND
PROUD TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL THANK
YOU FOR RAN FOR IT.
OTHERS SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS.
.
I CERTAINLY AGREE.
THERE'S CLEARLY FUNDING GAPS IN
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING FOR
YOUR BILL.
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION FROM.
MISTER HARPER ANYTHING FROM
SOME EVER BIGGER MASSACRE WOULD
LIKE BECAUSE I'M. MIDDLE OF
SCIENCE AND I APOLOGIZE WHICH
ARE CLOSE.
SO.
NOW THAT EVERYBODY'S GOT IT OFF
THEIR CHEST HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THE POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR BY SERVICE
TO SCHOOLS.
OKAY NOW I MENTIONED THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN HERE ARE SOME OF
OUR WITNESS BOTH FOR AND
AGAINST.
SPOKE.
AT LENGTH ABOUT HIGH SPEED RAIL
BUT THE REALITY IS THIS IS ABOUT
GETTING OUR KIDS TO AND FROM
SCHOOL IN A SAFE AND EFFICIENT
MANNER WE EVERY MEMBER HAS KIDS
IN THEIR DISTRICT. WHO HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING TO SCHOOL
EITHER BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
CAN'T AFFORD? TO PAY FOR THE
MONTHLY BUS FEE AND IT IS NOT
CHEAP BY THE WHEN YOU HAVE TO
PAY PER CHILD NAM THAT FIVE THEM
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S NOT. IT'S
NOT AN INEXPENSIVE VENTURE I'M
EITHER THEIR PARENTS DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO PAY FOR THE SCHOOL
BUS OR THEY'RE JUST WITHIN THAT
CERTAIN DISTANCE WHERE THEY
DON'T QUALIFY. TO GET ON THE BUS
THEIR VARIETY OF REASONS ARE A
LOT OF AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE
THERE ARE NO SIDEWALKS IT'S NOT
SAFE EVEN FOR THEM TO BE WALKING
TO SCHOOL. SO WE'RE GOING TO
PASS LEGISLATION THAT FUNDS.
MEAL PROGRAMS FOR KIDS TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE FAT IN THEIR BRAINS
HAD THE ENERGY THEY NEED TO
LEARN DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND MORE.
RESOURCES FOR THE TEACHERS AND
WE'RE GOING TO PUT ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS INTO THE SCHOOLS.
WHEN IT MAKES SENSE IF WE MADE
SURE THE KIDS COULD ACTUALLY GET
TO SCHOOL.
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING
I THINK THIS IS A NO BRAINER
LET'S JUST GET THE KIDS TO
SCHOOL VERY SIMPLE THAT'S THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLES GETTING THEM
THERE.
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING IS FOR THE
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THESE KIDS
GET TO SCHOOL SAID THEY CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
PUT INTO PLACE. TO GREET THEM
WHEN THEY WALK THROUGH THE DOORS
AT THEIR SCHOOL EACH MORNING
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
BUT THE USE OF THE MEMBER. MA'AM
SECTOR WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. FRAZIER.
FONG FONG AYE AND WE ARE CURRY.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN NOT VOTING CHIU.
DALY.
DALY NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO GIPSON.
GIPSON NO HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
IN THE MEDINA NO NESS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
A WILL KEEP THEIR OPEN.
THANK YOU.
I SEE WHERE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EGGMAN I WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM TEN.
AB TWENTY SIX WHEN I.
PLEASE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
MOON AND GOOD AFTERNOON DEVICE
YOUR MEMBERS TODAY AND
PRESENTING AB TWENTY STE
SIX TWENTY NINE. WHICH IS A BILL
TO ELIMINATE THE CODITION THAT
AN AIR SPACE THAT WOULD THAT
THAT THESE TWO AGENCIES LEAST
BELOW WERE FREEWAY EXCHANGE IN
MY DISTRICT. A BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION THE
CITY STOCK DOES NOT EXCEED A TEN
YEAR PERIOD RIGHT NOW IT IS
EVERY TEN YEARS I HAVE TO RE
RELEASE IT.
RELEASED THAT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR AGENCIES WHO HAVE
BEEN IN EXISTENCE SINCE THE
EIGHTIES TO BE ABLE TO PLAN FOR
LONG TERM PLANS.
IT IS MAKES IT MUCH EASIER IF
THEY ARE ABLE JUST TO CONTINUE
TO GO FORWARD THERE ARE NO
BUYERS FOR THIS.
THIS AREA THAT SITS UNDERNEATH
TO COURT TO FREEWAYS AS THEY
CROSS OVER. AND SO EXISTING LAW
RIGHT NOW REQUIRES A DO THAT
EVERY TEN YEARS WE WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE THAT.
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY HAVE
EDWARD FIGUEROA BEHALF OF SAINT
MARY'S DINING HALL AND RAY CALL
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STOCKTON
SHELTER FOR THE HOMELESS AND AS
WE ALL KNOW. AS WERE OUT WORKING
TOWARDS TRYING TO DEAL WITH OUR
HOUSING CRISIS HOMELESS ISSUE
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE PROVIDING THIS CARE WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO. REMOVE AS
MANY BARRIERS AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
ARE ARE GOING TO PROCEED
I DO.
I HIGH OTHER STOCKTON SHELTER
FOR THE HOMELESS HAS BEEN
SERVING THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
HOMELESS POPULATION SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. OUR
CAPACITY HAS GROWN STEADILY OVER
THE YEARS FOR SERVING ONLY MEN
THAN MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN TO
THE POINT THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY.
AT OUR CURRENT CAPACITIES THREE
HUNDRED PER NIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS NEED IS
GREATER THAN OUR CAPACITY.
SO ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT WE MAY
HAVE.
SIXTY MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
SLEEPING ON MATS ON THE FLOOR
AND OR MULTIPLE MOBILE
MULTIPURPOSE ROOMS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND OUR
SHOULDER CAPACITY ON SITE BUT
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER
THE PROPERTY WE ARE RELUCTANT TO
EXPAND OUR EMERGENCY. SHELTER
CAPABILITIES
THE CURRENT SHORT LEASE TIMES
MAY MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO CONDUCT
CAPITAL CAMPAIGNS TO RAISE
FUNDING FOR THE FOR MORE SHELTER
BUILDINGS.
THE SHORT LEASE TIMES ALSO
CAUSES TO HAVE TO JUSTIFY OUR
NEED FOR MORE LEAST TIME EVERY.
TIME THE LEASE COMES UP BECAUSE
OF US TAKE ATTENTION AWAY. FROM
THE DAILY NEEDS AT THE SHELTER.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
FOR PROVING AB TWO SIX TO NINE
WHICH WOULD EXTEND OUR LEASE
ALLOW US MORE STE STABILITY IN
PROVIDING OUR SERVICE TO THE
HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND SO WE CAN GET.
THE NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M EDWARD
FIGUEROA CEO FOR ST MARY'S
DINING ROOM AND ST MARY'S DINING
ROOM HAS BEEN PROVIDING CARE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES HOMELESS SINCE
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE AND DOING SO
IN OUR CURRENT LOCATION SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX UNDER THE
CROSSTOWN FREEWAY. OUR
ORGANIZATION RESPONSE TO POVERTY
AND SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY BY
FEEDING THE HUNGRY CARING FOR
HEALTH ISSUES IN RESTORING HUMAN
DIGNITY TO OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS EACH AND EVERY DAY.
ON OUR CAMPUS WE PROVIDE A
DINING ROOM THAT PROVIDES
BREAKFAST LUNCH AND DINNER THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR.
HYGIENE CENTER WHERE OUR CLIENTS
ARE ABLE TO SHOWER TAKE CARE OF
THEIR HYGIENE NEEDS RECEIVE
CLEAN UP. SEASON APPROPRIATE
CLOTHING AS WELL AS CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES WHERE WE
HELP OUR CLIENTS IDENTIFY WAYS
TO MOVE OUT OF HOMELESSNESS IN
INTO SELF SUFFICIENCY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDING ACCESS TO
CLINICIANS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
ALSO ON OUR CAMPUS WE PROVIDE A
MEDICAL CLINIC AND A DENTAL
CLINIC AND ALL THE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED FREE OF CHARGE.
AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
SAID AND MY COHORT.
RAY CALL MENTIONED A LONG TERM
LEASE WOULD ALLOW US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAN MORE
EFFICIENTLY EFFECTIVELY.
ESPECIALLY WHEN LOOKING AT
FUTURE CAPITAL PROJECTS TO
SECURE FUNDING.
DEMONSTRATING THAT WE HAVE LONG
TERM SITE CONTROL I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN DAVID JONES
ABOUT THE CITY OF STOCKTON
SCRIPT THAT WE ASK FOR MY VOTE.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT IS THERE
ANY OTHERS IN THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
HI EMILY ABOLISHED WITH THE
STOCKTON SHELTER FOR THE
HOMELESS AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THE VOTE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE THIS COMMENTER
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
SEEING NONE.
A.
WE HAVE.
WITH A THIRD AND FOURTH.
OR ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT LIKE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
OUT WE SHOULD CLOSE.
I JUST THINK YOU VERY MUCH IN
ADVANCE FOR THE SUPPORT OF THIS
A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE JUST
MAKE THINGS EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO TO DO THE BUSINESS OF
HELPING OTHERS.
TYPE PERSON VOLUNTEERED AT
SAINT MARY'S REPEAT OF SIX YEARS
AND I IN TURN STUDENTS SO THEY
COULD GAIN CLINICAL SPIRIT
SKILLS AND BE ABLE TO HELP
PEOPLE OUT THERE AND I CAN. I
CAN TELL YOU HAVE FIRST HAND
THAT IF WE PROVIDING VITAL
SERVICES TO KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE
UNTIL THEY CAN WAIT MAYBE MAYBE
NEXT DAY TO BE ABLE TO GET SOME
SOME FURTHER HELP SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MUCH WE HAVE A FIRST
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
A GIPSON.
THAT KNAPSACK THAT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRAZIER.
FONG FONG AYE AND WE ARE CURRY.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE CHIU.
DALY DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER. HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
THE BILL DOES EIGHT ZERO AND WE
WILL KEEP THEIR OPEN.
SEE MR HOLD IN THE AUDIENCE WILL
NOW MOVE TO. FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN A BETWEEN NINE
EIGHTEEN.
A PLEASE BEGIN WE READY.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE A TEAM WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
INCLUDE IN THE CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S HANDBOOK INFORMATION.
REGARDING A PERSON CIVIL RIGHTS
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
THE DRIVER'S HANDBOOK INCLUDES
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO CONDUCT
ONESELF DURING A STOP. BUT
STOPPED SHORT OF STATING THE
RIGHTS OF THE DRIVER AND WHAT TO
DO IF THE SITUATION IS
ESCALATING.
BEING INFORMED OF THESE RIGHTS
ARE CRITICAL IN SITUATIONS THAT
CAN QUICKLY GO FROM CALM TO
WORSE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN CALIFORNIA ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY TRAFFIC STOPS.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN CELL
ADDRESS THE EXTENT AND
LIMITATIONS OF THE PEACE
OFFICER'S AUTHORITY DURING A
TRAFFIC STOP. THE LEGAL RIGHTS
OF DRIVERS AND PASSENGERS AND
DETAILS ON THE PROCESS FOR
FILING COMPLAINTS AGAINST A
PEACE OFFICER.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
DEVELOPED BY THE DMV AFTER
CONSULTING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND CIVIL JUSTICE.
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
I GIVING INDIVIDUALS SPEAKING IN
SOME SUPPORT.
YEAH. I'D TIFFANY PULLEYBLANK
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS
IN THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR THIS BILL.
CENA ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ARE THERE ANY.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE BILL.
OKAY WE.
HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY MISS HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOHN.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THE REASONS FOR
THE BILL AND.
VERY MUCH AGREE THAT.
.
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE UP
PROMOTION AND BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF OF THE RIGHTS
OF THE PEOPLE DO HAVE THE
QUESTION I DO HAVE. A RIGHT WHEN
IT COMES OF THIS BILL IS IS THIS
THE RIGHT VENUE.
TO BE DOING SO WHY IS THIS SITE
EDUCATION BEST DONE BY IS A PART
OF THE DMV EXERCISE.
THROUGH THE GOVERNMENT OR IS IT
BETTER DONE.
THROUGH.
CITIZENS ORGANIZATIONS.
AND BOTTOM UP AND SO IF YOU CAN
GIVE SOME REFLECTIVE THOUGHTS ON
ON WHAT YOU THINK I'M WILLING TO
LISTEN UP BUT THAT'S THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE IS WHETHER THIS IS
THE RIGHT VENUE OR.
OR IS ANOTHER BIT
MORE APPROPRIATE
THAT MAY BE LESS GOVERNMENT
SENT.
YEAH WELL I THINK I THINK
CERTAINLY ON AN ISSUE LIKE THIS
YOU. CAN REALLY ATTACK THE ISSUE
FROM A VARIETY OF PERSPECTIVES
AND AT DIFFERENT LEVELS. AND
CERTAINLY HAVING DMV ENGAGED ON.
OF BEING A PART OF THE
DISSEMINATED OF INFORMATION TO
HELP. EDUCATE.
OF THE DRIVING PUBLIC. BUT ALSO
IT IS IN A TWO WEEKS. OF STREET
IT'S ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY NO PUN
INTENDED VERSUS OPPORTUNITY FOR
A LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SORT OF BE
ENGAGED IN THAT CREATES A BETTER
DIALOGUE INFORMATION AND
INFORMATION SHARING. A TOO OFTEN
WE SEE.
CONFLICTS HAPPEN AND MAYBE THEY
DID NOT NEEDS TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
THEY COULD HAVE BEEN.
.
REDUCED BASED ON INFORMATION AND
HOW BEST TO ENGAGE UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES CIRCUMSTANCES AND
SO WE THINK THAT THERE IS A ROLE
THAT THE DMV CAN PLAY WE'RE
LOOKING TO THE DMV TO. UMPS TO
HELP DRAFT WHAT THIS APPROACH
WITH LOOK LIKE AND THE LANGUAGE
AND SO I THINK THAT BY ENGAGING
THEM HAVING THEM VIA STAKEHOLDER
IN THE PROCESS I THINK THAT
ALLOWS US TO. GET THE MAXIMUM
OUT OF THEIR INVOLVEMENT.
BUT THAT'S ALSO THE START TO
SAY THAT THERE AREN'T.
COMMUNITY WIDE EFFORTS AND
OTHER.
EDUCATIONAL VENUES WHERE
DISCUSSION AND INFORMATION CAN
BE SHARED BUT WHEN YOU'RE GOING
TO GET A LICENSE TO OPERATE
VEHICLE ON THE ROAD. THIS IS AN
ELEMENT OF.
I THINK THE CONVERSATION THAT
GIVES US A.
A MORE APPROPRIATE OR A BETTER
VEHICLE OUT TO SHARE. OF THE
INFORMATION APPROPRIATELY AND
AND TO BE HONEST WITH YOU THIS
IS LEGISLATION THAT WE.
HAVE.
PICKED UP FROM THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
WHERE?
HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND IT
WAS RECOGNIZED AS AN APPROPRIATE
WAY TO MOVE FORWARD.
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND
ENGAGING THE PUBLIC. THAT I
THINK.
MORE INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE
THE BETTER THOUGH BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO OPERATE.
INDIVIDUALITY OF A TRAFFIC STOP.
AND NOT TO CREATED DYNAMIC WHICH
WOULD CAUSE. AN ESCALATION.
I IN THE SITUATION.
AND JUST THE FEEDBACK THAT I'LL
HAVE IS HIGH I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER TODAY.
ALLEN TEND TO HOLD OFF BUT I'LL
BE LISTENING.
TO STAKEHOLDERS TO CITIZENS
SIDE AND TO OTHER PARTIES AYE IS
THE PROPOSAL PERHAPS INVOLVES OR
PERHAPS I GET MORE INPUT ON IT.
IF WE NEED DAY MAY COME TO THE
FLOOR SOME OTHER PART. OF THE
PROCESS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ITS
REPRESENT WHICH.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
OF WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
OF AS I SAY I THINK IT'S OF AN
IMPORTANT A NEXT STEP
APPROPRIATE WAY TO ENGAGE THE
PUBLIC AND HOW TO.
INFORM ON HOW ON TRAFFIC STOPS
TO. AVERT ESCALATION AND
POTENTIAL ISSUES THAT ARISE FROM
TRAFFIC STOPS AND
MISUNDERSTANDING SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN WE HAVE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
I WAS AS CLOSE AS WE'RE PAST
THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT HEADS UP IN.
MISTER HOLMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS A SEAT AT THE
TABLE.
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
DRIVERS WHO UNDERSTAND THEIR
LEGAL RIGHTS WHEN THEY ARE BEING
PULLED OVER.
HOWEVER I QUESTION IF THE DMV
HANDBOOK IS THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO HAVE INFORMATION. ON
HOW TO FILE A COMPLAINT AGAINST
AN OFFICER. NONE THE LESS I
WOULD SUPPORT A BILL TODAY. AND.
LOOK TO WORKING WITH YOU HAN
MOVING THIS FORWARD.
I WE HAVE A FIRST BY MR MEDINA
SECOND BY MISTER HARPER.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
FRAZIER HYPE FRAZIER AYE FONG
FONG AYE AND WE ARE CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHAU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
COVER NOT VOTING MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA INEZ ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
IT IS FIVE FIVE VOTES WILL LEAD
ROLE BEEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER.
IT'S TO RUSSIA PUT IN. AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY
SIX PLEASE.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY SIX WHICH
CREATES A PILOT PROGRAM THAT
ENABLES CALTRANS TO UTILIZE JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING. FOR ROUTINE
TRANSPORTATION MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS
JOB ORDER CONTRACTING IS A
SIMPLIFIED CONTRACTING PROCESS
FOR MAINTENANCE OR SIMPLE
CONSTRUCTION WHICH REDUCES COSTS
AND TIME FOR NEW PROJECTS.
UNDER CALTRANS ROUTINE SIMPLE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WOULD
INCLUDE PAVEMENT REPAIR ROUTINE
BRIDGE MAINTENANCE AND STORM
WATER MITIGATION.
JOB WERE CONTRACTING HAS BEEN
USED FOR OTHER PROPUBLICA WORKS
PROJECTS HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
PROVIDE EFFICIENCIES TO REDUCE
COMPLETION TIMES AND LOWER
COSTS.
IN JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CALTRANS OUTLINED THE POTENTIAL
A JOB ORDER CONTRACTING
ACHIEVING ITS TARGET
EFFICIENCIES EFFICIENCIES GOAL
OF A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. THE ESTIMATED SAVINGS
OF APPROXIMATE APPROXIMATE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS USING JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE CALTRANS
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO UTILIZE
THIS PROCUREMENT PROCESS
ACCORDING TO ESTABLISHED
PROCEDURES SET BY CALTRANS.
TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY SIX WILL
REQUIRE CALTRANS TO SUBMIT AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
DEAL DETAILING THE STATE OF ALL
CURRENT. AND EXPIRED CONTRACTS.
DURING A TIME OF SIGNIFICANT
VESTMENTS ARE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE BEST PRACTICES SO OUR
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS ARE YOU
SUFFICIENT
OFFICIALLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE BIGGESTFONG HAVING
WITNESSES SUPPORTER DO NOT.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE THIS TEST FINDS FOR
THE AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ELECTED TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
VOICE OPINION THE AUTHORS BILL.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST BITE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HARPER SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAKER.
SINGLE CLUMSY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTER PHONES LIKE
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WAS FONG FOR
PRESENTING A BILL TODAY.
I HOPE THAT YOU PROPOSAL CAN
LEAD TO A MORE EFFICIENT
CALTRANS.
WELL CONCERNS WHAT IMPACT THIS
BILL MAY HAVE ON LABOR.
BUT CSUS BUT I SUSPECT IT WILL
BE ADDRESSED AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD.
A WITH THAT I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PULLEYS CALLED.
THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG AYE AYE FONG AYE AGUIAR
CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHAU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE THIS ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
THAT HAS SIX VOTES WILL KEEP TO
RULE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ON
A PASSED THE GAVEL BACK OVER TO
MR FUNG AND IT'S MY TURN.
MUSICAL GALS.
BUT WE WERE STARTING WITH THAT
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN A BETWEEN AYE
NINETEEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN. PLEASE PROCEED
WE READY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE NINETEEN
WHICH AIMS TO CREATE CERTAINTY
AND PREDICTABILITY FOR VITAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
BY REQUIRING ENVIRONMENTAL
PERMITS TO BE APPROVED WITHIN
TWO YEARS.
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS CAN TAKE
MANY YEARS TO BE COMPLETED DUE
TO THE MULTI STAGE DEVELOPMENT
AND REVIEW PROCESS THAT INCLUDES
INVITE HIM ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REVIEW AND MITIGATION.
DESIGN AND ENGINEERING RIGHT OF
WAY ACQUISITION FINANCING
CONSTRUCTION PERMITTING AND
OTHER RELATED REQUIREMENTS.
ONE ASPECT OF THE TRANSPORTATION
DELIVERY PROCESS IS. IS THE
PERMITTING OF PROJECTS FROM
VARIOUS RESOURCE AGENCIES.
ANECDOTALLY IT WOULD TAKE A
PROJECT SPONSOR MONTHS TO TWO
YEARS TO GET THE FINAL PERMIT
APPROVAL FROM THESE AGENCIES.
OFTENTIMES PROJECT SPONSORS AND
AGENCIES GO BACK AND FORTH AND
BACK AND FORTH.
AND BACK AND FORTH.
WITH NO REAL CERTAINTY OF WHEN
THE PERMIT WILL BE APPROVED.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE HOW DO YOU
EXPECT TO MOVE PROJECTS FORWARD.
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S NO REAL
DATA TO SHOW HOW THESE DELAYS
ARE AFFECTING PROJECT DELIVERY
IN INCREASING. OUR PROJECT COSTS
DRAMATICALLY.
MY GOAL WITH THIS BILL IS NOT TO
UNDERMINE OUR ENVIRONMENT AYE
AYE ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
AND I NO THIS BILL IS NOT THE
PERFECT SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM.
HOWEVER THIS BILL SERVES AS A
VEHICLE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH KEY EXPERTS TO
BETTER ADDRESS PROJECT DELAYS.
REDUCE COST AND OVERALL.
PROVIDE THE CERTAINLY NEEDED TO
SUCCESSFULLY DELIVER PROJECTS
WHILE PROTECTING. THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS BILL ALSO ENSURES THAT
STATE AGENCIES CONVENE.
THAT THE.
PERMITTING TASK FORCE THAT THAT
WAS MANDATED BY LAW TO ADDRESS
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
PROJECT DELIVERY.
AS CHAIR OF THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEES MY RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE PROJECTS ARE DELIVERED ON
TIME.
AND ON BUDGET.
WITH ME ARE EXPERTS IN THE FIELD
TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY. IN THE
DRAMATIC NEED FOR THIS.
PLEASE PROCEED.
BUT RESEARCHER MEMBERS BECAUSE
CAREER ON BEHALF OF THE SAME
TALE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WHILE OF THE AUTHORITY
DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL WE DO
SUPPORTING CONCEPT WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
I WOULD THINK THAT IT IS VERY
COMPLIMENTARY TO LEGISLATION
THAT WAS ENACTED LAST YEAR I AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO IT'S IT'S
REFERENCED IN THE BODY OF THE
ANALYSIS. HAD THAT BILL CREATES
A TASK FORCE FOR CALLOUSED HERE
IN NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. TO
ASSESS THE VERY THINGS THAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DISCUSS AND
AGAIN I THINK THAT. WITH THIS
LEGISLATION IT'S IN TROUBLE
TRYING TO GET AN EFFICIENT
TIMELINE TO DELIVER THESE
PROJECTS.
SAVE MONEY AND HAVE THE PUBLIC
ENJOY THE BENEFITS OF PUTTING
THEIR TAX DOLLARS TO YOU SO WITH
THE FORTY CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION I AM ALSO REACHING
OUT TO OTHER TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AGENCIES.
TO ASSESS AND ARE DESCRIBED
DIFFICULTIES THAT THEY'RE FACING
TO HELP BOB MOVE THIS BILL FORD
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY.
I THINK THE MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. AYE WE TO HAVE A
SUPPORT IN CONCEPT POSITION
SUPPORTIVE OF WHERE THE AUTHOR
IS TRYING TO TAKE THIS MEASURE
IT DOES NOT YET AT THIS TIME
APPLY TO LOCAL AGENCIES
SPONSORED. PROJECTS BUT IT IS
OUR HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
HIM AND HE EXPERTS HE BRINGS
INTO I ADVISE HIM ON THIS BILL
THAT WE COULD BECOME PART OF.
.
PART OF THIS PERMIT STREAMLINING
PROCESS THE SACK FOR A LONG TIME
HAS SOUGHT EFFICIENCIES IN THE
WAY WE DELIVER PROJECTS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU OFFER ON THIS
STUFF. MITHRIL.
I THINK VERY MUCH AIR OTHER ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC EYE LIKE
TO ASSIST BECAUSE FOR THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEN
NONE.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE THE
QUESTIONS OF THE OFFICE.
I THINK. IT WILL BE VERY HAVE A
FIRST AND SECOND BUT THIRD
FOURTH WILL BE ADDED.
.
OF. THE MISTER CHAPMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
JENNER.
WITH S. B. MONIES FLOWING WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY ENSURE THAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE GETTING THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THEY DESERVE.
DELIVERED EFFICIENTLY.
AND COSTING MUCH LESS BECAUSE OF
THE EFFICIENCIES THAT ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD WITH THIS
PROCESS.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WAS UP
IN SEATTLE AT THE PORT
CONFERENCE IN LEARNING ABOUT
HOUSE SEATTLE PROPER IN CANADA
DOES THIS INSTEAD OF A. KIND OF
A LINEAR FASHION OF WITH
AGENCIES OF APPROVAL MORE OF A
VERTICAL.
ATTEMPT WERE AGENCIES ACTUALLY
TALK TO EACH OTHER ALL AT ONE
TIME GOING FORWARD.
AND.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RIVAL.
WE HAVE A FIRST FROM A SUMMER
RALLY ARE CURRY A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA. AND.
STREAMING I APPLAUD YOU ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS OF A TO GET CAN
SOME PROJECTS DONE.
I'M I'M EXCITED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL SO MEDICARE WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE FRAZIER AYE
FRAZIER AYE FONG. FONG AYE
AGUIAR CURRY AND WE ARE CURRY
AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY. DALY AYE
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE ELEVEN NOTHING. LOCAL THE
ROLL OPEN.
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE AS CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ALSO AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE WILL
HELP THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY BE THE GOOD
NEIGHBOR WE WANT TO BE WITH. THE
PROPERTY OWNERS.
THUS FAR THE THORNIEST PURCHASE
MORE THAN THIRTEEN HUNDRED
PARCELS OF LAND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. TO BEGIN THE INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT AND EX AND
EXPECTANT NEED FIVE HUNDRED MORE
PARCELS. FOR THIS FIRST PIECE OF
THE SYSTEM.
MOST OF THESE PARCELS ONCE PER
PURCHASE SIT EMPTY INTO
CONSTRUCTION CAN FINALLY REACH
THEM.
EMPTY BUILDINGS AND LOTS ARE AT
BEST A NICE OR IT CAN BE A
MAGNET FOR CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
IMPACTING THE SURROUNDING AREAS.
THEREFORE WE HAVE BEEN THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME REPORTS.
OF TROUBLE WITH PROPERTIES CURLY
OWNED AND SITTING IN VACANT AND
SITTING VACANT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
WE DON'T WANT THIS TO BECOME
ANOTHER REASON FOR THE PUBLIC TO
OPPOSE THIS EFFORT.
AS THIS PROJECT MOVES FORWARD
THE STATE IS GOING TO NEED TO
ACQUIRE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY.
WE HAVE TO BE SURE THIS PROPERTY
IS SECURED AND MADE SAFE.
MY BILL SIMPLE.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE
AUTHORIZES THE AUTHORITY TO
CONTRACT WITH THE HIGHWAY PATROL
TO ENSURE THAT SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THE PROPERTY'S
PURCHASE.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
MOVING FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC EYE
LIKE IT'S BEEN OPPOSITION THIS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
A SCENE NINE MISTER CHAIR WAS A
CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A FIRST FROM AS A MEMBER
CHIU AN A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY.
EVENTUALLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MISSION IS DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING AND WE ARE
CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN IHEU.
CHIU I DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE.
THOSE NINETY TWO OVERALL OPEN.
PERHAPS A MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES
IF YOU DO A LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING
WHILE WE WAIT FOR MISTER BONTA
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SP
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE.
AB. AB TWENTY SEVEN SIX ONE. A
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE AND WAS
TOLD BY THE AUTHOR.
WILL TAKE A COUPLE MINUTES AND
WAIT FOR MISTER BONTA.
WE CAN GO AHEAD AND RUN THROUGH
A COUPLE OF THE.
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS JUST TO TAKE
SOME TIME.
I WOULDN'T. RULING DIFFICULT ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE CURRENT
VOTERS NINE TO ZERO BAKER.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
CHIU. CHU AYE GIPSON.
NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE.
TWELVE TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
NINETY EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTERS
THREE TO SIX BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING BERMAN.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
NINETY A.
BERMAN NOT VOTING TO.
JUNO GIPSON.
NAZARIAN.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO
SEVEN.
I WILL MOVE BACK INTO HER
REGULAR. MEETINGS WITH THE
MISTER BONTA.
MISTER BONTA ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR.
EFFORTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
NINE. AND THANK YOU TO STAFF FOR
THE WORK YOU PUT INTO THE
MEASURE. A. B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
NINE WILL IT THE CITY OF OAKLAND
BY PROVIDING ANOTHER TOOL TO
ADDRESS THE GROWING.
HOMELESS CRISIS THIS PROGRAM
ALLOW THE CITY OF OAKLAND POLICE
UNUSED PARCELS BELOW ARE NEXT TO
STATE FREEWAYS. FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTER OR FEEDING PROGRAMS FOR
ONE DOLLAR. PER MONTH
SIMILAR MEASURES HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN SAN FRANCISCO
SANTA BARBARA AND SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY WITHOUT THIS BILL.
THE CITY VOCAL HAVE TO PAY FAIR
MARKET VALUE.
I WOULD BE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
AND I WITH THIS BILL WE CAN
TURN.
AYE AYE AND ACTIVATED UNUSED
PARCELS TO A HIGHER MORE OPTIMAL
USE AND. BY PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO A CERTAIN
CALTRANS PARCELS FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS AND FEEDING PROGRAMS
THIS BILL WILL HELP THE CITY
ADDRESS.
A GROWING HOMELESS CHALLENGE AND
PROVIDE SERVICES TO A GROWING
HOMELESS POPULATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION RESPECT
THE ASP DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU
MISTER MONTE OF WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT I DO. YES FUTURE NAME
HERE REPRESENT MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICHOLAS CAM
HERE WE HAVE OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF.
WERE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
WE WANT TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA FIRST LEADERSHIP. OF A
VERY QUICK WE HAVE A DECLARED
HOMELESS CRISIS IN OAKLAND WE
HAVE OVER TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE LIVING ON THE STREETS WE
CAN ONLY HOUSE ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE.
OF THIS BILL IS ONE OF MANY
OPPORTUNITIES WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS YEAR TO HELP
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS.
ONCE THE PARCELS ARE LEAST THAT
THE CITY OF OAKLAND WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAINTENANCE
AND I BILL LEE ASSOCIATE WITH
EMERGENCY SHELTERS.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF WAS
REPEAL THE AUTHORS.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY THE AUTHOR ARE OF
THE AUTHOR. MR MATHIS.
HA.
MS ROS IS A GREAT HILL.
MITIS WISH I I I HAVE A SIMILAR
ONE THAT'S.
CURRENT FOR VOTE ON THE DYESS.
EVH NINETY EIGHT THAT OPENS THE
SAME PROGRAM OF FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE.
SOLEMN I'M HOPING WE CAN GET.
BOTH ARE MEASURES THROUGH HILL.
ON SO WE CAN PROVIDE THIS FOR
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE INSTEAD OF JUST INDIVIDUAL
CITIES NOW.
I APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS YOU KNOW
THAT THIS IDEA STARTED WITH ONE
JURISDICTION AND THEN ANOTHER
SAW THAT THAT WAS IN THE
PRUDENCE OF IT AND THAT THE
POSITIVE IMPACT YOU CAN HAVE AN
ENGINE AND THEN ASK FOR THE
SAME.
OPPORTUNITY AND THEN ANOTHER AND
AT SOME POINT I MIGHT GET A
CRITICAL MASS WHERE WE DO THE
STATEWIDE AND I DON'T KNOW I'VE
SEEN THAT PATTERN HAPPENED
BEFORE. RIGHT NOW WITH MY BILL
WHICH IS ASKING FOR IT FOR
OAKLAND WHERE THERE IS A
DECLARED HOMES CRISIS BUT I
DON'T THINK OAKLAND IS THE ONLY
PLACE THAT CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
SUCH A PROGRAM.
HE NEVER MET A MEMBER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
I HAVE A FIRST BY THE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU SUNG BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO WHOM. MEDINA.
HOMES BUT WHICH ARE CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT WITH
YOU TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE FIGURE MISTER BONTA
FOR BRING THIS BILL FOR TODAY.
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL AND HOPE
THAT IT MIGHT HELP TO SEE LOCAL
ADDRESS IT'S HOMELESS POPULATION
IN NEEDS. AMOUNT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MACHINIST YOU PASSED IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. AYE FRAZIER
AYE FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING AND WE ARE
CURRY.
AND WE ARE CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY. DALY AYE
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA AND.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT IS ABLE LEAVE OPENS OR HAVE
SOME MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
BONTA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
STAFF.
SO WE'RE GONNA WILL BACK TO WELL
IF YOU CALLS ON. FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SPENCER IT WOULD YOU
TAKE OVER WHERE YOU LEFT OFF.
FILE ITEM TO AB TWO ZERO TWO SIX
THE CURRENT VOTERS TEND TO ZERO
BERMAN.
BERMAN I AGE YOU.
CHIU AYE GIPSON.
NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIVE A THE TWO THREE
THREE SIX THE CURRENT VOTED SIX
TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU I.
NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWO FOUR NE
EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTERS TEND TO
ZERO BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE MATHIS
MATHIS I AM IS ARYAN.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THIRTEEN TO
ZERO.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWO FOUR NINE
TO THE CURRENT VOTERS ELEVEN TO
ZERO BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHU CHU
AINA SYRIAN.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM NINE A BE TWO FIVE
THREE ZERO THE CURRENT VOTERS
THREE TO THREE FRAZIER.
ALWAYS
WHICH ONE.
YEAH.
NO. CREATION BUILDING THOUGH
FRAZIER NO AGUIAR CURRY.
I AGREE I CARRY NO TO.
JUNO MATHIS
MATHIS I'M IS ARYAN.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO SIX.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TO SIX TWO NINE
THE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE AG WE ARE CURRY.
TWO SIX TWO NINE.
AND WE ARE CURRY AYE CHIU.
TWO I'M MATHIS.
MATHIS INEZ ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWO SEVEN
ONE TO THE CURRENT VOTERS THREE
TO FIVE BERMAN.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY TWO
SEVEN ONE TWO.
BERMAN NO CHIU.
JUNO GIPSON. GIPSON KNOWN AS
AREA. MS AREA NOW.
BAKER VOTE CHANGED FROM NOT
VOTING TO AYE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO NINE.
FILE ITEM TWELVE.
WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWO NINE
ONE EIGHT.
THE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TWO ZERO
AND WE ARE CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY I BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE A DAILY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE NONSENSE.
FRIEDMAN I MATHIS.
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
CURRENT VISIT TWELVE TWO ZERO.
FILE IDM FOURTEEN AB TWO NINE
ONE NINE CURRENT VOTE AS ELEVEN
TO ZERO GIPSON.
GIPSON INEZ ARYAN.
NAZARIAN AYE CURRENT VOTE
THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. TWO NINE
NINE SIX CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO AGUIAR CURRY.
AND WE ARE CURRY I AM BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS I IN THIS AREA.
YES SIR.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I CURRENT VENT
FOURTEEN TO SARAH.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB THREE ONE
THREE FIVE CURRENT VOTE IS NINE
TO TWO GIPSON. GIPSON AYE AND
SYRIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
TO TO.
VOTE CHANGE BAKER I'D TO KNOW.
CURRENT EVENT TEND TO THREE.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB THREE ONE
THREE NINE. CURRENT VOTE EIGHT
TO THREE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
NAZARIAN.
AS AREA AYE CURRENT VOTE TEND TO
THREE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTERS TWELVE TO ZERO GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE.
FINAL VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
NINETY EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO SEVEN GIPSON. GIPSON
KNOWN AS AREA.
THIS AREA NOW.
CURRENT VOTE THREE TO NINE.
THE CHAIR.
I BE OFF THE AUTHOR CAN I. ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION ON THAT ITEM
A. B..
EIGHTEEN NINETY EIGHT MATHIS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
FILE ITEM TO EIGHTY TWO ZERO TWO
SIX CURRENT VOTERS TWELVE TO
ZERO GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
NAZARIAN.
YES.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
YES SIR.
VIOLATE HIM FIVE CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT TWO ZERO NAZARIAN.
YES SIR.
THIS AREA NOT VOTING FINAL VOTE
EIGHT TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B. TWO FOUR
ONE EIGHT CURRENT VOTE IS
THIRTEEN TO ZERO NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWO FOUR NINE
TWO CURRENT VOTERS THIRTEEN TO
ZERO NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWO FIVE THREE
ZERO CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO SIX
NAZARIAN.
MS AREA NOW FINAL VOTE FOUR TO
SEVEN.
I'M BE UP THE AUTHOR AND LIKE TO
ASK RECONSIDERATION FOR AB
TWENTY TH
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY MELENDEZ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED BAIL
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
FILE ITEM TEN.
AB TWO SIX TWO NINE CURRENT
VOTERS THIRTEEN TO ZERO
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
IT'S ALREADY BEEN CALLED.
THE LAST ONE I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
DURATION FOR IS ITEM ELEVEN
EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN TWELVE ALAN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
CONSIDERATIONS GRANTED BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE HIS HEARINGS ARE